Texas because it is a Bastion of freedom  and strength and alpha male energy and  Liberty and what words am I forgetting  here Freedom patriotism all that stuff  they have decided to essentially  compartmentalize their electrical grid  so that when there is a shortage due to  extremely cold temperatures or extremely  hot temperatures or for whatever reason  when there is a shortage of electrical  power they are not able to just draw  from neighboring grids and utilities the  way almost all if not all of the rest of  the United States is able to do now  Texas did this because they're a big boy  they're so strong you're such a big boy  Texas and yet it fails almost every year  it seems like and as a result of the  failure  they end up polluting even more